j'ai toujours été passionné par les
sciences
depuis tout petit quand on donnerait ce
que je voulais faire quand je serai plus
grande
je ne répondais pas maîtresse ou
princesse mais astrophysicienne même si
je reconnais que j'ai eu un petit
passage danseuse étoile quand j'étais
adolescente je participe et donc à des
stages consacrée à l'astronomie et ge
était la plupart du temps la seule fille
une fille pour trente mecs de 15 ans
pendant deux semaines vous les voyez
venir les techniques de drague vaseuses
abbas d'étoilés de constellation les
filles ne s'intéresse pas aux sciences
il y a un réel manque d'intérêt des
filles pour les sciences dures c'est ce
qui fait qu'il y a très peu
d'informaticienne ou de mathématicienne
alors que la plupart des secrétaires ou
des infirmières sont des femmes on va
regarder quelques chiffres pour se
donner une idée 44,6 c'est le
pourcentage de filles en filière
scientifique au lycée dans suite c'est
le pourcentage de filles en école
d'ingénieur en 2012 21 c'est le
pourcentage d'ingénieurs qui sont des
femmes seulement un ingénieur sur cinq
est une femme en 2005
larry summers qui était alors président
de harvard donne son explication à la
sous représentation des femmes dans les
sciences il dit je le cite que les
femmes possèdent moins de connaissances
intrinsèques pour les mathématiques que
les hommes je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais personnellement cette
explication qu'on vend assez peu les
femmes ou inventé beaucoup de choses
comme par exemple les rayons x les
gilets pare balles ou les premiers
algorithmes mais alors où sont les
prochaines marie curie où sont les
futurs grasshopper on va faire un petit
test qui parmi vous dans la salle avait
quand il était petit un déguisement de
chevalier de cowboy outre ou deux
pirates
le levé la main on voit pas très bien
mais ça a l'air d'être des garçons
et un déguisement de princesse ouais bon
là c'est que les sacs à déchets il a
pour le coup
en fait les petits garçons vont beaucoup
s'identifier à des pirates à des
astronautes à des corsaires alors que
les petites filles vont quasiment
toujours s'identifier à des princesses
une princesse c'est joli c'est mignon
c'est délicat
et puis surtout ça a besoin du prince
charmant pour être secouru et alors que
les petits garçons vont devenir des
explorateurs du monde et d'au-delà et
bien les filles vont devenir des petites
choses coquette qui prennent le thé avec
leurs poupées du coup les petites filles
développe beaucoup moins leur curiosité
que les petits garçons alors mon chez
moi ça a dû rater quelque part parce que
je suis d'une curiosité maladive et j'ai
passé mon enfance à faire des
expériences plus ou moins foireuse maman
je fais absolument désolés pour les
poissons rouges que j'ai tout en mettant
de l'eau de javel dans l'aquarium
voulais juste je voulais juste voir ce
que ça donnait et ont comme les petites
filles développe beaucoup moins leur
curiosité que les petits garçons elles
se tournent moins vers les sciences et
au moment de choisir leur orientation et
bien elle se tourne vers d'autres
domaines
al'inverse les petits garçons ou une
très forte pression sur leurs épaules au
moment de choisir leur orientation
et comme la société attend beaucoup
d'eux eh bien ils deviennent ingénieurs
alors certes l'éducation des parents
joue un très grand rôle dans
l'orientation des enfants mais il ne
faut pas oublier que l'école joue un
rôle au moins aussi important vous
reconnaissez cette tête là mais si c'est
la tête de toutes les filles avant un
dess de maths
toutes les filles avant un ds de maths
sont convaincues qu'elles n'arriveront à
rien qu'elles n'ont rien compris que de
toute façon leur vie est fichu du coup
c'est peut-être là vous la reconnaissez
aussi ça c'est le garçon qui arrive les
mains dans les poches le sourire aux
lèvres
les révisions sont éphémères le talent
est éternel tout ça tout ça
les garçons doute beaucoup moins de
leurs capacités que les filles ils vont
plutôt à remettre en cause des choses
sur lesquelles ils peuvent influer comme
par exemple l'efficacité l'existence de
leur travail
c'est là qu'intervient ce que claude
style qui a été professeur de
psychologie sociale à stanford et
columbia
appelle la menace du stéréotype en fait
c'est l'idée qu'a force de square
mauvais en maths et bien les filles
finissent par le devenir
pour illustrer sa je vais prendre une
étude qui a été menée en 2007 par un
français sur quatre cent cinquante
élèves de 6e et de 5e à peu près tous du
même niveau scolaire
l'idée pour les enfants c'était de
mémoriser une figure à base de carré et
triangle et ensuite de la redessiner on
a divisé ce groupe en deux sous groupes
et au premier on a présenté ça comme un
exercice de géométrie et au second comme
un exercice de dessin kan s'était
présenté comme un exercice de dessin les
filles ont beaucoup mieux réussi
l'exercice que les garçons alors que
caen s'était présenté comme de la
géométrie baelde ont beaucoup moins bien
réussi en fait les filles de tellement
de leurs capacités que le simple fait de
leur dire qu'elles vont faire de la
géométrie
c'est à dire des mathématiques s'est
cruellement baisser leurs performances
alors même qu'elles sont tout à fait
capables de faire l'exercice puisqu'elle
y arrivent très bien quand c'est du
dessin ce mécanisme s'appelle l'auto
censure l'autocensure des filles a
beaucoup de conséquences
déjà elle ne s'oriente pas vers les
métiers estampillé métier d'homme comme
par exemple le métier d'ingénieur et
comme il ya très peu de femmes qui sont
ingénieurs comme je le disais au début
eh bien elles ne sont pas prises au
sérieux imaginez un homme qui devient
sage femme
eh bien il va être assez peu pris au
sérieux par ses clientes et par ses
collègues
et bien c'est le même principe une femme
qui devient ingénieur va devoir se
battre au quotidien pour prouver qu'elle
est aussi bonne techniquement qu'un
homme et elle va très souvent devoir
expliquer qu'elle n'ait ni assistante ni
secrétaire quand elle décroche son
téléphone
ensuite une équipe plus diversifiée est
une équipe qui va être beaucoup plus
efficace plus on va avoir deux femmes
enfin plus on va être proche de la
parité dans une équipe plus les gens de
cette équipe vont venir d'horizons
différents en fait plus on va avoir
potentiellement de points de vue
différents dans cette équipe
plus elle va être créative et ça dans le
domaine scientifique c'est quand même
quelque chose de très important
alors c'est vrai dans le domaine
scientifique mais en fait
c'est vrai dans n'importe quel autre
domaine par exemple
gloria bâche qui a été qui était membre
du conseil d'administration de la banque
morgan stanley aux états unis disaient
que le manque de femmes dans les équipes
dont qui était donc constitué
essentiellement d'hommes poussait ses
équipes à prendre de très gros risques
voire même parfois des risques
complètement inconsidérés elle dit même
que si lehman brothers s'était appelée
lehman sisters et bien il n'y aurait
probablement pas eu de crise en 2008
enfin le manque de femmes dans
l'ingénierie pose un problème de
représentation
comme il ya très peu de femmes qui sont
ingénieurs et bien les jeunes filles
n'ont pas de modèle féminin d'ingénieurs
elles n'ont pas une personnalité à qui
elle pourrait s'identifier et du coup le
domaine de l'ingénierie devient quelque
chose de très obscur de très mystérieux
et même de très masculin en fait du coup
elles n'ont pas envie de silence de ceux
de se lancer dedans et ça ne rassure pas
non plus leurs parents qu'elle se lance
dedans donc du coup et bien elles
choisissent de ne pas devenir ingénieur
du coup on a un cercle vicieux
peu de femmes sont ingénieurs donc peu
de filles le deviendront la question qui
se pose du coup c'est comment briser ce
cercle vicieux
alors tout d'abord on peut se contenter
d'attendre depuis le début je dresse un
portrait assez pessimiste de la position
des femmes dans l'ingénierie mais en
fait il ya de l'évolution par exemple on
a récemment atteint la parité dans le
domaine de l'eau chez les hommes chez
les jeunes diplômés
aujourd'hui les femmes représentent 50%
des effectifs des moins de 30 ans alors
qu'elles ne représentent que 13% des
effectifs de plus de 45 ans mais il ya
toujours des domaines qui ont du mal à
recruter
par exemple le domaine du numérique où
le domaine du bâtiment
ensuite dans les écoles d'ingénieurs il
ya également de l'évolution
si on regarde ce graphique et bien
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 30 % de
filles dans les écoles d'ingénieurs et
d'ici 2060 15 on devrait atteindre la
parité mais 2075 c'est loin et dans un
monde où on a beaucoup besoin
d'ingénieurs dans un monde où il ya
énormément de défis technologiques à
relever on ne peut pas se permettre
d'attendre 2075 c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
faut pousser les jeunes filles à devenir
ingénieur
alors pour ça il existe de nombreuses
associations
un peu partout en france et dans le
monde on peut par exemple citer elle
bouge qui a récemment créé un
partenariat une délégation dans le nord
de la france en partenariat avec liam
télé le doigt ou alors femmes
ingénieures et puis dans le même esprit
je fais partie du projet hashtag je suis
ingénieur qui sensibilise les élèves du
lycée châtelet à doit à chaque fois
l'idée est la même on va agir sur le
problème pas de modèle l'idée ça va être
de faire rencontrer aux jeunes filles
des femmes ingénieurs qui travaillent
dans l'industrie pour qu'elle ait des
modèles des femmes el kihal puisse
identifier également pour démystifier le
monde de l'ingénierie
mais la meilleure façon d'accélérer la
transition vers la parité dans les
domaines scientifiques
c'est changer les mentalités il faut
changer notre façon d'éduquer les
petites filles il faut les pousser dès
l'enfance à devenir curieuse et
ambitieuse par la suite il faut les
pousser
il faut les encourager dans les deux
dans les matières scientifiques quand
elles doutent de leur capacité afin de
limiter leur auto censure en fait s'il y
avait une chose qu'il fallait retenir ce
soir c'est que la transition vers la
parité dans les domaines scientifiques
c'est un moyen d'émancipation pour les
filles c'est un moyen de se libérer des
carcans de la société et des stéréotypes
qu'elle lui inflige finalement pousser
une petite fille à s'intéresser aux
sciences aujourd'hui c'est lui permettre
demain d'être une femme plus autonome
plus indépendante
c'est lui permettre plus tard de devenir
une aventurière intrépide plutôt qu'une
princesse en détresse
merci vous
[Applaudissements]